now by the way it's no coincidence what
kinds of functions are going to land
your opponents if you have no many
shapes regions don't make sudden tools
is one of the fun things you get it is a
stationary point in the middle you're in
trouble
can you see why that stationary point in
the middle may interpret your piece and
you fool it's gonna go twenty above this
nation for might belong depends on what
kind of shape again okay so now let's
add a few more of these changes let's
say okay so now I've got a few more of
these values in Thea drawing you're easy
okay and you can see but the press of
that you know increased accuracy is I'm
gonna have to work out more action areas
so I need to be able to talk about all
of this and label you know what are all
these bits and pieces so I was gonna
call remember we said the highest part
that's a big lead but it's perpendicular
so that's that's one now I'm going to
call the height of each of these strips
or sub intervals that's another name I'm
going to call the pitch
say
okay now do they have to be cool I mean
in theory I can make whatever your PC
owners on work I can make something
become something small but later ball
and what I'm gonna try to simplify this
you'll see why it's probably gonna be
more valuable to us if they are so H is
consistent perpendicular height okay no
I've got my a and my B here and then
I've got all of these intervening
x-values okay so because I've got a
whole bunch of them I might have more or
less how am I gonna name that what I'll
just name them in order the X values 1 X
1 X 2 X 3 in this case I've gone up to X
before it doesn't tend to go water
because it's not making the question is
just all right now by the way just
following the convention right can you
see that it's funny if I kept going yeah
instead of calling it a and B I might
equally for it and sometimes you see
textbooks or exams or videos I might
call the first value X 1 X 2 I might
call it X 0 or X naught no that's not x1
rebel but more importantly okay but it's
your last value right 1 2 3 4 and
identified that 5 is significant because
it's the number off the trapezium these
years the numbers repeated I've got
because I have patience okay now this
age that I've just I just called it the
perpendicular height okay just like an
opportunity example I actually can work
out okay because what I'm gonna do it is
I'm going to take the whole interval
that I've got this area on which what do
you say wonderful the whole interval
well I'm starting it ain't going to be
it's B minus a but each one of these
days I'll be cool baby right so I'm
gonna divide goodbye however many
sections I okay now I know this is
starting to get a bit long in the tooth
but it takes weeks all these bad way to
introduce another hello
so watch out this is this is an H and
this okay
some people post sections or trapeze
but I have okay okay there's the first
trapezium now go to the next one now it
has the same height so still got an H on
- okay but the two parallel sides I've
got one of them is shared from the first
revision because one of the trapeze use
that yes
so I've got f of X 1 and then the next
one over X 2 okay - time to get ready
for so how many of these am I gonna have
they're all this stagnation on the last
one will be well in this case I had to
text and okay so that's it that's a bit
of a page right out so can you sit is
well they all have this common factor H
on two and then what do I have here well
every single term is going to pair up
except for the first and the last ones
right
they're kind of dumb learners on the
outsides right there and a lot so
therefore you've got F of a just one and
then two of all these ones in the middle
and instead of going all the way up
until the end of which you have one okay
now sometimes you might see this written
that it might even help you to remember
this but what you've got evening here is
you've got the first one so all the
middle ones okay why are we telling all
of these new bodies because every time
you work out the next piece of motor
block you talked a lot on that parallel
side that's why you got done with those
okay so that's the that's the that's the
formula you started off with just one
trip easier and this is what happens
when you okay all right yeah